hey yo what's going on this china mac
check me out on a [ __ ] bootleg
cab podcasters
[ __ ] get it
boule care podcast special guest my boy
chyna mac is here
yo what up what up bootleg kev what's up
buddy you out here going viral
and [ __ ] yeah i'm just trying bud trying
bro i'm trying to tries to fail
yeah man you know i'm starting my own
[ __ ] and it's going great yeah good to
see you
uh good to see you good to see that yo
it's crazy uh
i was just in your hometown and now now
you're out here
right in your hometown it's not my
hometown i'm from phoenix
all right where i currently call home
right in fact los angeles
how was new york how'd they treat you
out there great man it was a
i heard you was in the trenches
definitely man but it was cool because
um
we're in brooklyn a lot of the time then
we're in the bronx and then
we went to uh talking with the woos out
there right the woos and then whatever
ron suno and his guys
yo shout out to ron sooner them some
wild boys right guys
so we're in the bronx that [ __ ] was
crazy right
i had to try the chopped cheese i would
never had a chopped cheese
i had it with barbecue ketchup which i
didn't know was a thing yeah
i guess ketchup mixed with barbecue
sauce from new york [ __ ] right
amazing yo i'm like yo these corner
bodegas the food is a
stellar that's that's where it's at bro
they they know how to they know how to
whip something up
what's your go-to when you're like at
like hitting up the bodega
i i i keep it i keep it on turkey swiss
cheese
on on a hero okay a little little you
know
he has some great chinese food in uh
canarsie shout out to i think we had
chopped hot wings and
pork fried rice oh you gotta have you
got it yeah you chopped them up
mm-hmm fire they put you on yeah i
wanted to talk to you man cause like
you you know with what's going on man i
i feel like it's important to kind of
touch base with you man because i you
know all this asian [ __ ]
is going on in these streets man it's
real [ __ ] up i just saw a video today
that really had me in
like a i think it was something you
posted actually you might have posted it
yeah
yeah it just hit me the wrong way man
and and you know i i manage um
one of my best friends is vietnamese and
my radio show producer is filipino and
it feels like there's something going on
right now
and uh yeah i just uh man
like kind of as a leader of the
community
first of all what do you think is it
that's happening and how can people like
kind of
you know i don't think a lot of people
they could repost it on social media
but what what are the things you think
that are actionable that people could do
to kind of
you know help out
what i think is going on is basically
um you know all of this [ __ ] is
um is a uh byproduct
of you know the coronavirus
you know i'm saying um and
you know where they saying they came
from china and and
and how how our
government and how the media
spun it you know what i'm saying like
you know with trump coming on
i think the china virus thing was like
you know what i'm saying like that was
that was a little i think that that kind
of made it okay for a lot of people to
like
kind of normalized making it about
race if you will as opposed to like what
it is you know what i mean
yeah that's exactly what they did you
know they they call it the
the kung fu the virus the the china
virus
like the way they said it and the way
the media the news was spinning it was
disrespectful right
you know because of you know whatever
whatever
um standings that america has with china
right whatever that is you know at the
end of the day i'm chinese but i'm
american
i was born and raised here like i don't
know i go to china they're not going to
treat me like i'm chinese what i'm
saying because i'm american
so i don't know what the [ __ ] is going i
don't know what's going on out there i
don't know right i mean but
because how they they they
they spin it in the media it makes it
look like all right oh well well it's
not just
the people if not it's not just the
government china
it's the chinese people right and in
america
we don't know anybody besides we don't
know any other
asian um ethnicities besides chinese
right everybody's chinese to a lot of
people you know
people so a lot of people right so when
you when you do that but
but everybody's not chinese asia is made
up of 48 different countries
there's malaysians there's different
languages
it's not like puerto ricans and mexicans
they speak different versions of spanish
but it's still spanish you're still
rooted in spanish yeah
we speak totally different [ __ ] like we
don't like 100
the culture is different everything is
different the food is different
it's a whole different world you know
i'm saying so now
when somebody like trump comes out and
says yo
the china virus the kung fu virus right
and then put it in a disrespectful
spin right now the media spins it
and then yeah sure it's like you know
everybody that's doing these things and
that's partaking in these things
aren't like trump supporters but it's
not just trump it's the whole media
like spinning this this this you know
this [ __ ] so now people
what we're seeing is a byproduct of that
you know what i'm saying like people
you know taking let's move this ashtray
people subscribing
to that [ __ ] yeah and then you gotta
understand the the
the the coronavirus shut the world down
for a whole year
for sure we never seen that before and
for china probably i mean well china has
probably handled it the most swiftly
right but in america
right in america our ship is shut down
for a whole year
right and that that [ __ ] up a lot of
things for people you know what i'm
saying
it made people stay in the house for
months uh uh
it messed up people's jobs businesses
you know what i'm saying people
people who needed me like mental like
like
you know any type of care or [ __ ] like
that they didn't get that
you know what i mean hospitals are
closing they're letting people go
police is pulling back you know all of
this is happening right
and with you know they need people need
somebody to blame
you know what i'm saying people need
somebody to blame like you know i'm
frustrated like all of this is happening
but you know
um and then so now when the media says
oh
it's the chinese virus it's the kung fu
virus yeah i'm saying then people gonna
respond to that you know what i mean
people that has mental disabilities
people that has like just
you know that just that that's just
messed up in their head
or people that's just frustrated that's
bored i just want to do some stupid [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying they're gonna
go and do this stupid [ __ ] and that's
what's happening right now you know
i feel like you know this is just you
know this is
this is this is the byproduct of that
and i don't feel like this [ __ ] is going
to go nowhere no time soon
because america and china
got their thing you know what i'm saying
whatever that thing is you know
it's definitely it's competition it's
their adversaries on the economical side
you know a hundred percent yeah what um
i think too a lot of it also is like i
feel like
two groups of people have always kind of
been the butt of a lot of jokes
in movies and comedy skits and i feel
like it's
it's people from india and
asian people right and which are asian
people right they're both
the constant innovation right but like
chinese you know
but but um
and by the way y'all have been cool all
these years
you know for the most part you know like
if you think of the stereotypes when you
watch movies that are
heavily played up you know what i mean
um
i also think that that has to do with
two like where it's almost like
like it it's sad that
something like this is happening that's
kind of making people realize like yo
like it's it's because that conversation
wasn't happening before these attacks
were happening it was just kind of like
like did do you feel that way as well
like or what kind of conversation just
the conversations of like hey like you
know like
it's not okay to joke on asians like
it's not okay to like
do this you know because i do feel like
watching movies in snl or whatever the
[ __ ] it is
asian people have always taken the
stereotypes and
on the chin like my homies who are asian
same way you know what i mean but i feel
like now there's like a real spotlight
like yo maybe that type of [ __ ] isn't
okay because it might normalize
or even like desensitize people to like
apply to be an asian like you know what
i mean yeah i mean
um yeah it's been normalized because you
know what but and that's to
um by the way you've done a great job of
calling that [ __ ] out for a while right
and that's because we ain't been calling
this [ __ ] out we've been letting this
[ __ ] slide we've been you know what i'm
saying we've been
we've been we've just been like you know
just taking it on the chin and
putting our hands down and [ __ ] like
that or you know most of us not all of
us right but
you know what i mean i guess whoever's
been in the spotlight you know i'm
saying whoever's it has the
had the ability to speak about [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying we ain't really
talking we ain't really putting up a
fight about [ __ ] you feel me
and i think that is a big reason
why this [ __ ] continuously happens you
know what i'm saying you let a
[ __ ]
you give a [ __ ] and she's gonna
take him out and you let a [ __ ]
take advantage of you
you're gonna be taking advantage of it
i'm saying so you know
and that's just so now where all of this
has happened and now
you know it's good to see because at the
end of the day
uh when when i first saw these ha these
things
uh uh transpiring i was the first to do
a
asian rally on like yo you know
calling out like like these attacks on
our people and it's not just our people
it's not just regular people these are
elderly
yeah that's like that's 89 year old
people like ah
like [ __ ] is wrong with people like i
don't understand what the [ __ ] is wrong
like 80
like [ __ ] is attacking all
people
you know who cares what race they yeah
they're all like yo how crazy is that
what kind of level up
they all like who the [ __ ] raised you
like like like what the [ __ ] you got
going on in your [ __ ] mind you
attacking somebody that's 89 years old
bro like you can't even are you [ __ ]
dumb
it's crazy stupid it's crazy and and a
lot of
the way the media is spinning it is like
all black people
are like that's a lot of asian people
feel like oh all black people
uh hate us and i'm i'm like you know
what i'm saying i'm outside with
black people all day like you know
all the people who i know that um are
active on the
black lives matter movement are also
active like going to protest for
for the is it for the stop asian hate
and all that [ __ ] but i do think
talk about that narrative because there
is a narrative kind of going on right
now that is something between
because a lot of these attacks have been
african americans on asians right
not all of them the stuff in atlanta was
some white dude who probably got no
[ __ ] in his life yeah
um but a lot of it you see a lot of
these videos and it's happening
you know um it's happening from the
black community
towards the asian community right let's
not say the black community
let's just say it's happening by
individuals who
yeah but but they happen to they're not
not the black community right right not
the black community but people
people who are black right you see a lot
of videos like that you know what i'm
saying
and i think that you know at the end of
the day
um
at the end of the day i feel like yo
these attacks
are not just happening from black people
towards
asian people these attacks are happening
i've seen videos white people doing it
i've seen videos of of of spanish people
doing it
it's everybody like you know what i'm
saying like it's not just black people
but you see a lot of these videos
happening i don't know why you know what
i'm saying i i don't know why
i don't think that it's because black
people
hate asian people i don't feel like that
because i don't know because i hang
around black people all the time
i don't i don't feel that it's not what
i feel you know what i'm saying what i
do feel
is that there are a lot of people
who um are subscribing to that [ __ ] a
lot of people who need to be in these
mental institutions you look at a lot of
these things that's happening right look
at that
in new york the guy outside the grocery
store like i think he was out of jail
for some crazy [ __ ] that he did it was
mom or something right he
killed his mother everybody everybody
that's doing this type of [ __ ]
i guarantee not everybody but a lot of
these people man
uh you're seeing like crimes of
opportunity but you're also seeing
mental health
mental issues you know what i'm saying
and and it's not just going to
like it's not just the asian community
that's getting
[ __ ] up right now a lot of people
crime is up
it is especially in new york especially
in different place certain places
like crime is up people getting shot
every day people
and it's not just asian people like i'm
saying you know it's a lot of people
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on it's a
lot of [ __ ] going on you know what i'm
saying like you know
and and and i think that you know i
think there's a
we have to just be mindful of why [ __ ]
gets spun
to us why all of a sudden [ __ ] is just
like getting fed to us
why all of a sudden like you know all of
this
infamous like all you see all these
videos just cater into one group and
then catering like it's just you know i
don't know algorithm [ __ ] man
right it's like that it's like whatever
you believe or you think they're gonna
keep on getting they're gonna make their
no matter what platform you're on
you could feel some type of way and that
algorithm will keep
they will keep reconfirming your
thoughts with whatever content they push
to you right
and that's what's [ __ ] up because like
like you said like if you're
if you're somebody who even like let's
say you voted for trump right or you're
a conservative because i'm not saying
all conservatives are bad i don't think
all people voted for trump are back
right
um i don't [ __ ] with dude but
it's like i see it on face like i stay
off of facebook but you know sometimes
on my but
facebook's [ __ ] up because like
anybody who already thinks
that this is what's going on they're
gonna
that [ __ ] is out there to just make them
double down on those beliefs
right and so if trump is pushing the
kung fu virus and the china virus and
all this [ __ ]
it's like people are just going to keep
seeing more [ __ ] about china and how
china is getting over on america and all
this [ __ ] it's like
i just feel like no matter what your
prejudice might be
your belief might be if you're online
and you don't step outside of your
social circle
you're never like you're just gonna
those beliefs are gonna get reaffirmed
you know what i mean like right
which is it's kind of crazy because
some something's got to give and then
you got people that that
and then you got people that just want
to like
you know promote the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
like this dude charleston white i seen
this stupid [ __ ]
like honestly i seen a couple of his
videos you know what i'm saying he
like like but he says some [ __ ] and he
kept on talking [ __ ] about the asian
people talking about us like we dogs and
[ __ ] like that talking about us crazy
and i seen him talk about other things
crazy too like he talked about
x he just he's the type of [ __ ]
that is that that old head that's always
online just running his mouth yeah
okay yeah i see yeah okay this bozo you
know what i'm saying he just want to
take something
that's hot and want to like like you
know what i mean or gas on like like
pour gas on it but he want to spin it
his way so he could like get clout and
get people to listen to him
and then and then he'll spin it a
certain way and then yeah i'm saying
like he
he he the type of [ __ ] that's
gonna get like
you know he's not he's no good bro he's
the type of [ __ ] that you start
listening to you
he he start putting dumb [ __ ] in your
head you know what i'm saying
like and and he's saying all of this
[ __ ] he says is crazy yeah i'm saying
but
certain [ __ ] he's saying like you know
he was talking about johnny dang right
and then he was just so i i hate asian
[ __ ]
every asian [ __ ] need the
[ __ ] die i don't give a [ __ ] i
spit on the asians he said
that's crazy man and i saw that [ __ ]
and that's just ignorant like that's
just
that's super [ __ ] racist i would
punch that [ __ ] in the mouth i
won't give a [ __ ] if he got 20
100 people with him man i'll punch him
writing this [ __ ] and we just gonna have
to get it we just had to get it with 100
[ __ ] bro
[ __ ] you mean bro you face your mouth to
say some dumb [ __ ] like that bro
like imagine if somebody else says some
[ __ ] like that to to another race like
to the
that would be crazy you know what i'm
saying i would never fix my mouth to say
no dumb [ __ ] like that to anybody you
feel me that's cool but this stupid
[ __ ] out here
promoting that [ __ ] like how has he not
been banned
on instagram or twitter there's a lot of
stupid [ __ ] out here man
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] like i'm saying
that's that's hate speech bro facts
that's hate speech
facts that shouldn't make me like that
[ __ ] make me upset bro
you know what i'm saying that should
make me upset [ __ ]
uh now i understand i understand like
the black community
and the asian community hasn't you know
we we have our differences you know what
i'm saying there's a lot of
there's tension but that tension ain't
never like asian mother
asian people ain't never [ __ ]
like rounded up black people
and did quit not in america i mean what
i'm saying hey look hey hey
there was japanese concentration camp
right in america like yeah dude we have
like
we have a lot of differences right
there's a lot of difference because it's
different cultures
you understand i'm saying asian people
come from different cultures everybody
look
the way i look at it is whether you're
asian you're hispanic you're irish
or whatever everyone comes from
whatever culture they're in right but no
matter what
we all have common ground
a lot of it is is based in cuisine a lot
of it is based in
you know maybe cinema or you know
there's people who love
yo how can you not love growing up in
the 90s and love
jackie chan movies you know what i'm
saying like there's so much like yo
where's common ground like yo like
everyone should have their own way of
life because that's culture right
but like we're all humans and and also
like you know
even coming up like your era like your
generation is probably the the
generation that's bridging the gap
for everybody like i feel like our
generation in general
that didn't grow up in the 50s and 60s
when [ __ ] was like real sex
or ultra-segregated like i feel like
like you said you we we're like i don't
even my friend group is so diverse it's
insane you know what i'm saying
right but no that's that hate speech
[ __ ] is crazy
i've seen that do [ __ ] too i don't
understand how somebody like that gets
banned like don't get banned
like on on these platforms like no like
no one like that should have a platform
and
be able to use it to promote that kind
of hate that's insane yeah but that's
that's like if that was if that dude was
a clan leader or something his [ __ ]
would get taken off
offline they would erase him they took
alex jones off
all platforms you know what i'm saying
like that [ __ ] is crazy
right i don't think i i think he's going
like viral
on on youtube and [ __ ] like that but
they gotta take his [ __ ] off right
that's crazy man
but i do think like you know at the
at the very least like there is some
sort of
dialogue being had now and i think that
that has never been had
right that's and that's and that's
sufficient that's why i try to use my
platform for
because at the end of the day i'm
chinese right but i was born and raised
in new york city i was born in brooklyn
i was raised in new york city but
i was also raised in chinatown with my
family
you know what i'm saying that sheltered
me in a chinese family but then when i
was like
seven eight years old i went into the
system group homes
uh uh boys home right detention centers
was there no asian people there
you know what i'm saying everybody was
from everybody was black
uh spanish puerto rican you know [ __ ]
like that you know what i'm saying
so i had to you know at a very
early age i just got thrusted into that
world right right but then at first
it was hard you know what i'm saying
because it's like i'm like a [ __ ]
unicorn
you know what i'm saying i think we said
that [ __ ] before
uh on the last interview on but i'm like
a unicorn in that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] and then you know i'm at
the butt of every joke
because i'm the only asian person there
so everybody got a joke
everybody trying to pick on me everybody
trying to so i had to learn
how to you know i had to learn how to
you know
bridge that gap you know what i'm saying
i had i had to fix some [ __ ] i had to i
had to assimilate
to that environment you know i'm saying
and what i learned is you know
from my experience you know yes i went
through racist [ __ ] people was calling
me all types of racist names all types
of [ __ ] like that
but that didn't come from a place of
hate
you know what i'm saying like i said i
think
uh you know it's it's been normalized
that asian people take jokes very well
right and it's you know it's it's on tv
it's on tv shows like you know what i
mean like
and like you said that's the company you
were keeping you're
probably the only asian dude around so
it was it was probably low-hanging fruit
they just cracked jokes
right and i'm guilty of cracking jokes
on my asian friends
that i mean in a playful manner
obviously we joke on each other we
know we bust balls but like like i said
like i think that like
the dialogue happening has never
happened before it's never but
i've been having this dialogue you know
what i'm saying because i'm always the
only you're always the representative of
yeah yeah yeah
and and and and people be like yo you
know
um oh you know
what whatever right like but i've been
speaking up for my
for for people that look this has been
happening yeah you've been very
speaking about this [ __ ] when in prison
you feel me righteous island um um we
ain't we in maximum we're in the maximum
houses
you know i'm saying the beacon 9a uh
uh seven b like like c74
[ __ ] [ __ ] going up in smoke every day
red alarms people getting cut
hectic crazy you know what i'm saying
asian people coming here
there's not a lot of asian people in
there bro and a lot of us a lot of asian
people that pull up in them spots don't
know english
you feel me because a lot of cuz because
so so when they pull up in there they
get
you know they get taken advantage of you
know i'm saying so now
when i i pull up in the spot you know i
mean i'm not going to say i'm the
toughest [ __ ] because i'm far
from the toughest [ __ ] right
but i ain't going to let nobody do
nothing to me you know what i'm saying
without me doing
like like fighting back yeah i'm going
to defend myself and if i can't live in
the house or we going to go up and smoke
i'm going to pop it off i'ma pop the
bottle and we out of there you know what
i'm saying and i'm not gonna live
nowhere
where i can't live like where you ain't
gonna treat me like a man you're never
gonna [ __ ] me you know i'm saying i'm
not gonna
sitting on the floor for nobody i'm not
gonna [ __ ] just
not get on the phone for nobody i'm not
gonna let nobody no nobody give me a
half a chicken
or a scoop of [ __ ] rice i'm fighting
i'm gonna bang that [ __ ] tray
all in your [ __ ] face
and i'm gonna get jumped by 20 50 people
and we out of there you know i'm saying
but
so i did that because i learned that the
only way for me to survive
in a situation like that is to give it
up you know what i'm saying and once i
give it up then [ __ ] gonna be
like nah
you know like like you know what i'm
saying they're not gonna do it i'm
saying so now when i see other asians
pull up
asian people look at me like i'm not
asian because
i don't have it i'm not you know what
i'm saying i was brought up different
you for me so when they hear me talk
they hear me
move they see how i'm maneuvering [ __ ]
they don't look at me like i'm asian
but at the end of the day i never let
how they look at me
dictate my
my stance for my people you feel me i
know that's some weak that's some weak
[ __ ]
you know what i mean like yo if people
look at them [ __ ] them i don't give a
[ __ ] about asian people like i'm saying
i hang out with with black people anyway
i would never do that
you know what i'm saying if i see
somebody even if they don't accept me as
an asian i'm always going to stand up
for the [ __ ] because at the end
of the day
i'm a representation for my people my
people is because
nobody's going to respect me if i just
let my people get yeah i'm saying
yeah i mean i remember you you i think
it was a little pump you called out yeah
but i mean
but like but you've but you've always
been a very
vocal representative as i should of
course
as if you weren't you people look at you
crazy
as i should and not enough amount not
enough asian people are doing that
you know what i'm saying not and i think
that's that's another reason why these
should these attacks be happening
because
a lot of us don't you know what i'm
saying we we we're not standing up for
our people we mind our business you know
what i'm saying but at the end of the
day
we you know i mean nowadays we can't
mind our business i see [ __ ]
i see videos men standing there
and letting people attack uh uh asian
elder or
a woman just oh you know they don't do
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] make me so [ __ ] mad how
about you gonna let this [ __ ]
come on the [ __ ] street
and [ __ ] and punch your old lady and
you're not gonna do you gonna let the
[ __ ] walk off the street
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bro ah yo bro i
think he's that security guard at that
grocery store who shut the door
right in new york i was like bruh who
the [ __ ] who raised that dude
crazy shut the door like bro you got to
go out like that's an old lady bro like
what the [ __ ]
like yeah nah nah i hear you man it's
it's it's
it's hard to you know like i said uh
yeah there there's there's
with every single situation there's some
silver lining and at least these
conversations are being had
yeah and that's the most important [ __ ]
that we have in these conversations and
and that people
are starting to open up and i think like
i was trying to say before
like between the black community and
asian community not enough conversation
has been had you know what i'm saying
and and it's just if we have more
conversation
then we will understand like hey you
know what i'm saying like not
all like it's not hate it's not we don't
no it's not hate from
other side you know i'm saying it's just
misunderstanding a lot of us need to
just
you know have these conversations you
know and as long as we have these
conversations
then more understanding will be and
that's what's gonna you know kind of
change certain [ __ ] but at the same time
all people got to step up bro like like
like we got a man to [ __ ] up like we
can't just be letting people come in our
communities
no matter what color they are they could
be [ __ ] purple you know i'm saying
whatever the [ __ ] they are
nobody should be able should be allowed
to come on
into the communities that's not of the
community and abuse people in the
community like
that [ __ ] shouldn't walk out
that [ __ ]
and that's any community that's not just
asian communities but
i know but i know for a fact like if if
if
if a a white person or asian person
would would walk in the middle of
crenshaw right
and just pick some random old black lady
you know what i'm saying
they ain't getting out they not getting
out [ __ ] is hopping out cars
and rightfully so as they [ __ ]
should
and that's any but i think that's i mean
look i'm talking about just human [ __ ]
like anybody who's a human
who's got a [ __ ] set of nuts you
can't just witness any human
like i don't care even if they're not
old like that [ __ ] is crazy like how do
you not step
up it's like if you watch some dude [ __ ]
up his girl in front of you and you're
just like hey they're my business like
bro that's
like bro you got it yeah but that type
of [ __ ] like look people like like
like somebody get into it what they
girling like you see someone do punch
a woman in their face you're like bro i
gotta i gotta just you guys
something as a guy i can't just like let
that fly
you know what i'm saying like so it
makes it worse if it's an old lady or
you know like f like you said
all race [ __ ] aside person to person
that's some wild [ __ ] to just
walk past and i know the thing about new
york is everyone's very good at minding
their own business
everyone just kind of is on their way to
wherever they're going and
right but you know that's just crazy bro
yo have to stop the bootleg podcast real
quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding us
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world
shout out to odd socks but they also now
got the drawls
man the boxer briefs are so fire
they're so soft they feel great on your
ass your nuts whatever you're into
you know what i'm saying whatever you
got they'll cover them up real real
comfortably
and ladies you know you could wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know one of the licenses they just
got that i love
are the naruto socks they just got the
naruto socks
of course they got wwe those are mankind
socks ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
ric flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks
thank me later save 20 off at checkout
by using the keyword bootleg kev
oddssocksofficial.com and we are
super proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it
what were your thoughts on um
the yg song getting
you know a song came out in 2013 right
um
and i i i liked the song as like it was
i mean it's a classic album in my
opinion i wasn't really a fan of
first of all this song's been out for as
long as it's been out so anybody who's
heard it
has heard it and i thought that the
whole outcry of it
if anything brought more people to
listen to the song um
but what were your thoughts on that song
kind of
getting cancelled i guess
i mean i i think i know
what say on it he said he said um
something find an asian neighborhood
and go in a house because they don't
keep cash and [ __ ] like that right
pretty much exactly what he said that's
basically what he said basically what he
said
okay
bruh i mean that's the truth
you know what i'm saying that's the
[ __ ] truth asian people
well you know what i'm saying since i
was a kid that's uh
asian people keep cash in the house they
don't like to go to the bank
you know what i mean and and they wear
they wear good jewelry you know what i'm
saying so if i'm a robber
i'm gonna go to the easy vic you know
what i'm saying i'm gonna go where i
know there's money why the [ __ ] i'm
gonna go here
ain't no money here oh they got money
they coming from the stores whatever
all right you know what i'm saying that
if i'm a robber it's not a race thing
you're forced it's not i'm not racist
doing it it's a crime of opportunity
and you make that available you make
that available then that
that's something that that's the
situation that you made available
you understand i'm saying so once people
start understanding what you're doing
then it's up to us to change it now i
don't think i think it was irresponsible
on his behalf you feel me but you know i
don't think he was talking i was he was
thinking about responsibility when he
made
that song i definitely think he was
irresponsible but it was his truth
it's his truth i don't think my thing
was when i started hearing people call
it quote unquote racist
and i'm like man i know yg like why
she's not a racist dude right
i don't think he was i don't think that
was a racist thing
i think that was opportunistic
opportunistic thing like that's that's
that's what
the people in their communities they
know like all right we gonna rob
[ __ ] we we know that they keep cash so
we gonna go over there he just said
what everybody in those communities
think you know what i'm saying
and if anything that should be game for
us to be like i
we gotta switch our [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
because they understand what the [ __ ] we
doing
you know what i'm saying and and i i
mean i don't think that
i don't really have i don't think that
you know um
them i don't really have a a take on
them pulling the song or keeping this
song up right
what i feel like is he just shed some
light
on what the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying or what the [ __ ]
is reality you know what i mean but he
definitely was
was he definitely like you know he
definitely was irresponsible in that
matter i don't think
you know now that he knows certain [ __ ]
i don't think he would say the same
thing
i don't think so i don't know right but
you know i don't think so you feel me
but um but yeah contacts 2020 right
right
but i don't think that taking down that
song does anything what the [ __ ] does
that do
yeah that's my thing is like what does
that do
except for make people be like wait
what's the song talking about let me go
find it cause you're gonna be able to
find it on youtube and find it somewhere
right like i think our people are
worried about the wrong [ __ ]
you worry about a [ __ ] song bro i
would also venture to say that whoever
created that outrage might not have been
and it sounds like some real like caring
ass white girls
woke twitter [ __ ] no but i heard asian
people talking about it
i'm saying asian people were outraged at
it you know what i'm saying
and but were they outraged like when it
came out
no because they didn't know about it you
know and the thing is is the song was
bigger than ever the first few months it
came out because that album was huge for
you but but here's the thing they
probably asian people probably knew
about it but we didn't say anything
about it
you know what i'm saying so now because
of all of this speaking up
okay we talking about this all right so
we will talk about this and talk about
this
talk about [ __ ] that [ __ ] ain't
talking about before you know what i'm
saying
it wasn't an issue before you know what
i'm saying but it's an issue now but
what i'm
all i'm saying is our people needs to
worry about
our [ __ ] like let's worry about what the
[ __ ] we doing wrong here yeah i'm saying
if we if we know that our parents and
our grandparents
don't yeah i don't carry cash we gonna
have to kind of shift them
to all right listen you keeping cash is
gonna make this is gonna make people
wanna come rob you and [ __ ] like that
yeah i'm saying
so we gonna have to shift we're gonna
have to we don't have to talk to our
elders
and we're gonna have to do some changing
you know what i mean you know
so i mean that's what it is people are
hurting out here
people there's a lot of people that
ain't getting money out here there's a
lot of people that's that's
that's homeless that very desperate in
the world right now so yes
yes um crimes against like asian attacks
is up but like i said before
crimes are everybody every every crime
is up
every crime is up you feel me so knowing
that
my brothers and sisters it's time for us
to [ __ ] change a couple things
out here we can't be doing the same [ __ ]
we was doing
two years ago because it's not the same
place you feel me
and if we keep on doing the same [ __ ]
without no change then we gonna [ __ ]
around
we we gonna catch a bad one you know
what i'm saying so that's what i feel i
feel like we
more of it more so the responsibility is
on us
to to to to to shift a couple of our
things
things that we weren't worried about
before now we should worry about
a couple things i'm saying our people
should be more you know
ready for for for different things you
know what i'm saying
because i think this world is changing
you know i think you know things
things are going a little you know what
are the um
actionable things you think you know
black mexican white whoever's watching
this that isn't a part of your community
but you know in the same way like i
remember when um
you know a year ago i'd like hit up
killer mike and i was like hey man
i want to help i just don't want to send
my money to some [ __ ] organization i
don't want to
and he was like yo boom boom boom these
are the three you know this is what this
thing you know
like like what are the actual things
that if somebody wants to donate or
somebody just wants to
try to help spread awareness or or even
things that they might be doing in their
everyday life
that they don't think about that might
be kind of adding to
you know maybe normalizing some of this
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying i i think
like you said you you basically the best
thing we can do
ourselves is just to check the [ __ ]
that that has been
um made normal that's been normalized
you know what i'm saying like certain
[ __ ] and
and before you every information ain't
good information you know what i'm
saying [ __ ]
is getting information from instagram
and facebook
and and [ __ ] like that and they take
that information and they run with it oh
my god i saw this this is true
oh my god that's the worst they see a
meme on and they think it's true like
who said this where's the worst part
about
our world right now is people just see
the meme or the headline and they assume
it's real and they
run there run outside oh look at this
[ __ ] i [ __ ] that and they'll they'll
base a whole [ __ ]
a whole um they'll base their whole
judgment
on on on a whole group of people and all
types of [ __ ]
off of one stupid that was something
that they didn't even fact check you
know what i'm saying you ain't gonna do
no
i mean i think that that's really a lot
of what happened with
the i mean the last however many with
this qa9 [ __ ]
that's a perfect people will see some
meme the qa9
was that oh man that's you're gonna die
down the rabbit hole on that one qa9 is
i try to keep it as short as possible
there was a reddit sub
a reddit thread uh where some guy
somebody uh posed as somebody who
was a part of the government that had
now mind you there's probably people
watching this who might be like yeah you
don't know
that had q level clearance which is like
the highest level of
intelligence clearance and was posting
these anonymous
tidbits about what was going on with the
government saying that
all of the democrats had like were child
molesters you ever heard of pizzagate
yeah yeah yeah so that was all through
qa9 so qa9
made up this this conspiracy theory that
there was kids getting raped in at this
pizza place
and that trump is like the savior the
reason why he became president was to
un like like pull the mask off of all
these like this pedophilia
ring going on in the government and they
literally think
that he's still the president so there's
people who
think that trump is still the president
behind the scenes and that biden they're
just showing everyone how biden's going
to fail miserably and then he's going to
come out and let everybody like it it's
the
most ridic bro the people who storm the
capital
those are qa non people so like they got
like a
bro it's the most
red like there's a doc they just put out
a like a six or seven episode mini
series on uh hbo about it
and dude if you see like the [ __ ] people
will believe
is scary because you realize like
nothing's too crazy
nothing's out of bounds where people
will like literally give up their entire
livelihood they'll
lose their job because they believe so
much in this
crazy [ __ ] like insane [ __ ] bro
like it's crazy look if you ever get
time
hbo just put out like a little six seven
part docu
series about it but really the
insurgents that happen
at the capitol that's qa9 [ __ ]
right and trump like shouted out q a few
times like yo shout out y'all
bro it's some wild [ __ ] bro yeah i think
like
you know we just gotta you know i mean
don't don't
don't you know don't just let somebody
um somebody's point of view on some [ __ ]
swear your [ __ ] you feel me take
everything with that fact check use your
yo you got common sense bro you got
common sense hopefully
you had some good guidance yeah i'm
saying you you you know i mean usually
you use your intuition don't let
[ __ ]
like you know poison your [ __ ]
head to do some dumb [ __ ] cuz look
i'm gonna tell you how crazy things are
right you could just look at history
look at history hitler
hitler right it took eight years it took
like eight to ten years for hitler
to fully make the people of
germany and also yeah people act like it
happened like this
no that [ __ ] took propaganda my brother
probably i'm saying so like
you know they use [ __ ] they use
the media they use these cartoons they
now it's so much easier though oh it's
so much easier because anybody can
spread pop everyone's media
right like you're a media media
everybody went on the street with a
phone
[ __ ] yeah you feel me so now more than
you gotta remember
like like like hitler they [ __ ]
they persuaded
a whole continent almost a whole people
to to [ __ ]
to to to agree to eliminate
a race erase a whole group of people
you know what i'm saying that's children
that's men that's
women that's that's that's they didn't
give a [ __ ]
that was evil bro and that was back then
that was back then
you know what i'm saying hitler would
have had a heyday nowadays right so this
is what i'm saying y'all you know what i
mean we have to understand
and and hitler did it through propaganda
did that hitler did it through the media
and it didn't happen overnight it
happened eight years at first
imagine he would have just came out and
be like oh we're going to kill all the
[ __ ]
oh they would have [ __ ] with him they
would they would have kid they would
have but he
slowly normalized the boom this is we're
suffering because of them
this boom that's why i was so cause like
boom
i got all the way to yo we just gonna
kill them all bro that's why i was so
like i would talk to people who would be
like and and i'm not a big joe biden fan
i don't like i'm i'm i'm a liberal guy
but i
i think joe biden is you know yeah he's
joe biden we know who he is
but donald trump being the president
any longer to me was so dangerous
because it just further normalizes
all of the [ __ ] he's already like think
about
if you got in a time machine it went
back to 2015
right as people were telling you some of
the [ __ ] that our president said you'd
be like man that's that's [ __ ]
or even the fact this [ __ ]
brought little pump out on stage at a
presidential rally
that was the simpsons moment for me brad
was like
we might be in a simulation this
[ __ ] brought little pump out at
a presidential rally
but i think like any more of like that
[ __ ] it just like like i think racism
has become
so normalized and it's and it's the the
division is at an all-time high because
and i you know i hate to put it on one
guy but man a lot of it's on that dude
and a lot of us on media too you know
what i'm saying but i really think that
like
the hitler thing you could kind of see
like oh yeah it makes sense how
you could slowly radicalize people
by already by just reconfirming whatever
stereotypes or hate they already had in
their heart for somebody right
like yo you're already scared of of this
this and this
i'm gonna just double down and play into
that fear whether it's about mexicans
and the border or
you know all of this [ __ ] like oh that's
all he did that's how he got elected
i know all these old like poor ass white
people already feel this kind of way
so i'm gonna make sure they pull up for
me because i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
feed them what they want to hear right
and that's why i was supposed to it's
about fear like you said people are
scared of [ __ ] and then you just keep on
feeding that just keep just putting a
little bit of gas over here and there
little things you know you're like
right yeah i think that's why i was like
no matter who the [ __ ] was running
against them i was like man look
it's irresponsible to even if you know
shout out to mitt romney
because i feel like mitt romney was like
the only [ __ ] who was a
republican
who never like he was anti-trump
the whole time john mccain who died you
know what i mean but like
yeah i just thought it was a it was
definitely an interest like like you
know
when it comes to asian americans
politically usually where do they fall
at least based on yours well you got to
understand asian um
asians are how about chinese americans
oh
i'm gonna i was saying more like towards
trump
more conservative yeah more conservative
you know what i'm saying
because they get money so like you know
any anybody with money it doesn't matter
if you're asian or
or well i mean yeah republic i mean look
less taxes right oh yeah
less regulation right so you know a lot
of chinese
are you know businessmen and there's
there's more money in that every year
right so you know they're gonna go
towards that
so you know but there's an asian
as you know the asian like you know it's
old it's a large
large spectrum that's right yeah a
hundred percent no 100 what's next for
you man like what are you working on i
know you know
um i got i got i'm about to shoot a
music video i'm i'm just
i'm doing my music but i took my music
off of uh streaming platforms right now
you know i'm saying why is it so
because um i was not
getting the return on my investment
on the music from the streams i just
wasn't getting enough streams yeah for
people who don't know like a million
streams is like
thirty eight hundred dollars on spotify
you know what i'm saying and i was
spending
thirty eight hundred dollars it's just
you know what i mean it's just to make
the song like you know what i'm saying
by the beach through the videos
i'm saying so if i'm in a red and i'm
not
and i'm not streaming a million you know
what i'm saying i'm not sure so i'm not
getting my bread
so it's just basically throwing my bread
you know what i mean and i'm not getting
it back and i'm thinking about other
ways to make money so it's kind of just
chasing a dream
that's like you know so i did that [ __ ]
for so long i'm just like
hold on bro you know what i'm saying
hold on
um um i was thinking about quitting like
you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah i mean
and uh and my bro shooter shooter 93
shout out to shooter
he he gets on my live and he's like yo
bro you know just
just just just i had already took my
music down because i'm like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] man i'm done with this [ __ ] [ __ ] it
i'm saying so shooter was like yo just
sell your music directly to your people
you fool me
and then and then get your bread and
then after once you get your bread
then you can do what you want you know
i'm saying the money is the issue right
so like
as long as you're getting the bread
right then you can once you have
once you amassed enough money then you
can do whatever you want you could play
however you want to play
i'm saying so i was like so he was like
yo you you did a good job
in cultivating a fire fan base yeah
right so now
and you got super like i got following
that you know what i'm saying
they must have been heartbroken you took
the music down right i was still on
itunes though
no no i mean some maybe like six songs
that's it right
damn mostly my collapse you know what
i'm saying mostly on youtube
i took all that [ __ ] down wow um i took
all of it down
would you consider putting it back up
because if you got some hardcore fans
they got to be like
man bro like right i mean i mean
i mean i might put it back up but right
now
um i'm selling it you know what i'm
saying so if if you're not hardcore
if you're if you're if you're a
supporter then then you won't buy it and
that's been working out
and it's been working out i made more
money in [ __ ] five days
than i made in the whole three years and
on music we know who's done a good job
of that
is uh rock rock marcy right shout out to
rock marcy my bro
shooter he does that tyler quality was
doing that for a while where you had to
like
go to his website to get music so at the
end of the day i feel like you know
as an artist we gonna have to just you
know every everything ain't for
everybody
you know what i'm saying like i have to
understand my market is different than
say
you know dude if you've got a thousand
people that'll just pay for what you do
it's gonna be good i'm good you know
what i'm saying so get your merch
popping
right hey look we got you could drop an
album once a month and
hit a check right and that's what i've
been cultivating you feel me just taking
advantage of the
the debates that i want to see so for so
long i'm
worried about chasing people versus
really
cultivating the people that already are
there you [ __ ] with me you feel me so
now
now i've just been focused on that and
then once i get my
my situation right then if i want to put
streams then at least i have to brag
to go crazy because right now us as
independent artists
you feel me unless we especially if we
do
genres that's different than you know
what's what's trending right now you
feel me
so like you know we have to you know if
we kind of in a race like we kind of in
a rat race we got to come up with
you know we have to pay for the stu like
the artist is the last person to get
paid
always you feel me like we got to pay
the the the producer gets paid director
gets paid the engineer gets paid
graphics guys graphics got
everybody gets paid then then after you
make the video and you make all that
then you got to pay the [ __ ]
spotify playlist
you gotta pay these people that people
blogs and all this [ __ ]
you know i'm saying oh you wanna do a
reaction video or y'all pay that pay
this pay that pay that
you were you kind of in that in that um
that that because you know like you said
you got to get to get some of these
youtubers to do a reaction video you got
to cut a check you got like a lot of
this [ __ ] is like everything is
everyone's getting a bag right now
exactly except
except the artist except unless you're
on tour
or you're [ __ ] like shout out to
griselda because griselda anybody on
their label like
conway benny gunn will drop a sweater
and make 250 grand off of it you know
what i mean like
but like in general they what they did
was they just focused
on who they who [ __ ] with them already
and then and then they grew it from
there you feel me
and they still make the same like i hate
when the [ __ ] didn't change well
i i'm like and they've they've obviously
out elevated in some of the sounds that
they but they're still them
right like a lot of times people will
make it and then they
violate their day ones or their core i
fell into that fantasy
uh expectations of them i i did that
you feel me and and like because i'm
like
you know like you were chasing whatever
sound was hot type [ __ ] or kind of you
know what i'm saying like i
so what happened was i [ __ ] um i came
out with the boom bap that rap [ __ ] you
for me and that's what they [ __ ]
before benny and them was pop i don't
know what they was doing at that time
right but they wasn't their names that's
what people were knew you for
was [ __ ] with me i'm saying and then
i had the song with dave east
jada kiss uh young and may and and and
what happened was
i did a song with dave east right
before he popped before he popped before
he signed the deal or whatever
i did it right the week before he he he
did that you know what i'm saying
and then young may i did that before the
old [ __ ]
when she was going viral on um
some freestyle she did i i reached out
to them too
and i got the songs and then me and dave
east
i dropped the video uh two days before
i was scheduled to drop the video i got
arrested
and i i did they sent me back up for 18
months
upstate right so
i dropped the ball you know what i'm
saying because now now i go i go upstate
davey's he he becomes he yeah he becomes
big at that time
i'm saying and then while i go upstate
i'm in i'm in i'm in
i'm in [ __ ] upstate box 23 and one
and i'm hearing people oh oh
and i'm like oh what the [ __ ] is that
they like yo young man i'm just like
damn damn bro uh and yeah i'm saying up
you know and and i came home and instead
of just like
keep on continuing with that boom bap
[ __ ] i'm trying to do
different [ __ ] i'm trying to like do
this sound and that sound and try
different [ __ ]
and i kind of confused my bass you feel
me to the point where it was like damn
what the [ __ ] you doing
and i kind of like that's so i i i fell
to like you know i did what you just
said
and what they did benny and them they
stuck to they sound
you feel me and they just kept on
growing it kept on going from there
and um that's you know so now what i'm
trying to do is do that you know i'm
saying just stick to my
what what my people love me for and i'm
gonna just keep on doing that and then
and also like you know i got some tv
shows online i was gonna say like you
could do a podcast i think it'd be
dope i think some of the youtube videos
you've done have been great like i love
that conversation between you and jen
that was fire like i think like
you're also known now as like more than
a rapper right
you know from the vlad interviews you
know what i mean like i think you could
definitely do
i mean yeah i got a bunch of [ __ ] online
i can't i mean on on
on complete uh coming i can't really
talk about right now
but definitely like game changing type
of [ __ ] different type of [ __ ] you for
me
and um i'm just constantly just just
pushing and working and trying to figure
out different things you know what i
mean so
you know i'm definitely you know
definitely i got my website
chinamaconline.com merch my music
you know different type of [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying hey last thing you just
mentioned
being in a box 23 hours a day one hour
out um
for people who don't realize it's
solitary
that's got to be what is that like man
and how hard is it to stay sane
in a situation like i should have drive
you crazy you feel me
if you just some people just
you know some people
can't be by themselves some people can't
do that [ __ ] you know i mean i should
drive them crazy
i'm saying but when i was in there i
just like
you know that [ __ ] was crazy bro
like you were here you this is madness a
mad house everybody uh
people fishing throwing you know people
just
as well and and you and you don't leave
that cell
and and with the box i was in you don't
come outside you like
like this is the cell they build another
unit right here right
this is like a little door right and you
walk out of your cell
and there's another little box like this
with a gate
with fresh air so you walk from out
yourself
to that little [ __ ] patio type [ __ ]
right and all you get is just that air
like like just and that's it you know
what i'm saying so it was 23 hours
of that like so
is that hour include like you showering
and all that type of [ __ ] or is that
well the jail i would just yeah yeah so
the spot
the showers don't turn on all the time
they turn it on
when when it's time for wrecking [ __ ]
and when you're in solitaire are you
alone
or do you have a celly well it depends
some some spots
is you're alone some spots you have a
cell so what would you do like to
just get through it was it reading is it
sleeping a lot
like you know what i'm saying like right
i was
i i read i read a lot i was like you
know push-ups
you know [ __ ] whatever i could do you
know i'm saying you know
talking to my bunkie playing chess you
know what i mean
i i fought a bunch of monkeys you know
what i'm saying like you know
um just i and i did i see
i did i did 16 months
on i did 16 months of that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
[ __ ] on regus island before you feel me
but that was single you know what i'm
saying so
you were by yourself for 16 months every
day right 23 hours a day well
i did i did so what happened was they
gave me
they gave me 20 months of that right
and then like on my like ninth month
i went upstate you know what i'm saying
and then i went back down
and then i did more months like so i had
a break but i did like nine ten months
straight to that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying by myself
would you just try to sleep as much as
you could through the day
you you made you make a [ __ ] like a
schedule you know what i'm saying so
you can't sleep the whole [ __ ] day
you know what i'm saying but you know
you get up
you know you do your push-ups you feel
me you eat your breakfast
you feel me you read your book you know
what i mean you talk [ __ ] on the gate
and then you just try to keep a regiment
you know what i'm saying keep a regiment
keep a [ __ ] like you know what i mean
and then you i'll try to read as much as
i can
i try to write as much as i can i just
use my time
to you know a lot of people don't though
a lot of people just be there beating a
dick
you know what i'm saying doing dumb [ __ ]
talking wow [ __ ] on the gate
you know what i'm saying and come out
box monsters you feel me like
you know crazy [ __ ] like yeah
because i can imagine like that could go
one of two ways you could either come
out of that like a lot stronger
you got to be strong or you could come
out of there
crazy kind of crazy kind of crazy full
crazy full [ __ ] that [ __ ] bat
[ __ ] crazy
because you'll meet those people who got
out of prison right and they're just
like
it didn't help it got [ __ ] whatever was
there got way worse
right [ __ ] was he walked in he
walked in crazy came out [ __ ] psycho
man well look i know you got to get to
the studio i appreciate you for coming
through
i appreciate you for having me bro the
website is chinamac.com
chinamaconline.com.com my instagram is
chinamac
my youtube is chinamactv and that's
where i'm at
you feel me boom there it is